لا يمكن فصل ما تسميه انقره حاليا بعمليه
المخلب السيف عن عمليه سابقه ولها عمليه
الدرع الفرات التي استمرت قربه سبعه اشهر
وانتهت في مارس اذار 2017
واسيطرت خلالها المعارضه السوريه بدعم
تركي على اعزاز وجرابلس ومدينه الباب بريف
حلب الشرقي وجاءت لعمليه العسكريه الثانيه
غصن الزيتون في يناير 2018
للسيطره على مدينه عفرين السوريه واستمرت
اربعه اشهر وفي اكتوبر عام 2019 كانت
عمليته نبع السلام وجاء بعدها اتفاق سوتشي
بين تركيا وروسيا ونص على الاحتفاظ بالوضع
القائم وتحكم تركي في عمق نحو 30 كلم من
الحدود شامله مدينه الابيض وراس العين
محاور المعركه دائره حاليا يمكن ان تتلخص
في ثلاث جبهات وهي عين العرب كوباني و
منبج وتل رفعت وهي مناطق تغلب عليها
الطبيعه السهليه دون وجود جبال صعبه او
معقده تؤدي السيطره على عين العرب كوباني
الى وصل منطقه النبع السلام ومنطقه درع
الفرات التي تتضمن اعزاز بوصفها عاصمه
لمؤسسه المعارضه عسكريا وسياسيا واقتصاديا
في الشمال السوري القائد العام لما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي كان
قال ان تركيا تريد الاستيلاء على عين
العرب كوباني
مدينه اعزاز شماليه حلب ومدن اخرى يعني
ذلك حرمانه وحدتها حمايه الشعب الكرديه من
حاضنه ومدينه اخذت اسم العالميا حين بدا
التحالف الدولي وحربه على تنظيم الدوله
وسيحرم ما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه من
اهم معاقدها على الحدود السوريه التركيه
بين نهري الخبور والفرات وقد اتهمتها انقر
باستهداف المدن الحدوديه التركيه انطلاقا
منها بقضاء في الهاون والمدفعيه اما منبج
المحور الثاني فتشكل اكبر معقل لما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه غربيه الفرات
وبالنسبه لمحور فيتضمن مطار مننا العسكري
في ريف حلب وبلده دير جمال وعشره الكره
الصغيره في محيطهما وهذه المنطقه بمثابه
عازل بين القوات المعارضه في اعزاز وقوه
النظام الشمال حلب